ich mach's turniere gerade was ist meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
hier zu einem spiel was ich beim girls
day gesehen hat und zwar clever bord das
ist ein spiel bzw
seine website wo ich mit dem clever bot
reden kann der soll angeblich clever
sein was sie allerdings bisher hier im
chat verlauf seht ist das ganze nicht
der fall
ich habe geschrieben hey darauf her b
dann ich was und er paläontologie dann
ich was bedeutet das wer wie was
bedeutet was und an der stelle sind wir
jetzt gerade ich gebe jetzt einfach mal
ein welche farbe hat meine unterhose mal
schauen ob der clever bot das erraten
kann
roth die fragen in eine andere sache
welche habe hat mein shirt man schauen
ob er das ergeht es hat die farbe
schwarz
wie kann er das wissen alter wie krank
ist das denn gut okay ich stelle ihm
noch eine kurze frage zur farbe
berichtet es einfach wissen möchte ob er
das wirklich irgendwie anhand der webcam
irgendwie das nach schaut welche
haarfarbe habe ich es ist nicht wahr ich
will raus ich das kann doch nicht wahr
sein als ob er das weiß welche farbe hat
meine hose
das kann er nicht wissen weil er die
jetzt nicht sieht wenn er das weiß dann
ist es logisch schottischen genau dass
die farbe form einer rose ich habe
übrigens gerade geduscht falls ihr euch
fragt was mit meinen haaren los ist es
gerade nichts drin wir fangen immer
etwas ganz leichtes wie spät ist es
gerade wir kommen gleich noch zu den
günstigeren sachen so sinn des lebens
und seinen schritt aber ich warte jetzt
erst mal ganz einfache sachen 22 21 bei
mir in deutschland zwei mal bist du dumm
es ist 0 47 08 48 ist jetzt gerade aber
also wenn er einen zweiten fall das kann
überhaupt auch gar nicht sein weil ich
muss ja 48 das ist ja überall auf der
welt wenn schon eine stunde verzug und
nicht so ein bisschen was mein gott du
bist nicht so clever wie ich dachte war
dies de 7 des lebens vieles okay was
bedeutet vieles und viele es bedeutet
für den chor bis das ist auf jeden fall
jetzt keine ahnung ich keine ahnung okay
der google übersetzer sagt kubisch was
tust du okay dann schauen wir mal wieder
beim klarer wird jetzt um ich
masturbiert gerade was ist das war
täglich auf der toilette machst was ist
mal summieren sich das entweder man
schauen was er darauf ich mache nichts
was willst du denn macht häftlings
freunde max lkw kran kraft das hat
glaube ich ein bisschen dran
deswegen tragen wir dem clever bot wie
betrunken ist krankhaft diese antwort
kann ich dann mit pee wees den scheiß
kannst du dich nicht mal konzentrieren
clever bot ich habe max nämlich gefragt
max bist du voll und seine antwort war
so richtig schlecht sprachnachricht live
aus der aufnahme an max hey mama beim
clever bot hier fink vom i mach ich
jetzt mal schauen was er dann sagt pj
mit pi pi denke dieser datiert schon
wieder von kaka julien link sehr clever
bot antwortet das junge gar keinen sinn
das ist genauso wie wenn man ihnen
unterhaltung für auf der straße in sonst
mordopfers lagers lama sagte gegenüber
einfach so mittendrin
hey das vorhin war er noch so klug und
jetzt kann er nichts mehr
ich würde gern total schreiben aber man
kann hier kein fragezeichen auf der
tastatur in anderer richtung machen und
ich kann auch kein akzent auf das
versetzen
deswegen geht die sonne auf spanisch
wasser
das ist doch nicht wahr was kann er den
baum hängt an mit spanisch und dann
kriegt er das nicht hin
what can you überhaupt
mal sahen live ja freuen ich habe extra
die rechte wieder da rein gebracht
ach so du kannst also alles ok dann
frage ich mal would be possible to bring
me right now ich hab grad sogar vom
training und ich habe bock auf pizza und
jetzt fangen den clever bord und was
antwortet der show if you don't remember
me das ist doch vollkommen egal
remember you that means necessary ist
das richtig geschrieben es bedeutet dass
du unnötig bist ja doch ich gebe der app
der app der website hier noch einen
versuch
ich stelle hier eine ganz ganz simple
frage und wenn sie die frage dann falsch
beantwortet ist vorbei und wenn richtig
dann ist richtig dass das ok das werden
wir mal so als vielleicht als
unentschieden würdest du mich heiraten
clever pott ich frage ob
ich soll einen guten grund nennen mich
zu heiraten legale box of the ghost
schon clever botnet compared to me a
okay du hast also eine größere box lego
so willst es also letzte titel what you
think about sex clever bot thank you
sweety ich habe nicht gesagt dass du
sexy bist ich hab dich gefragt ist auch
komplett egal much alkohol did next
rinkes evening ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob das korrekt des englisches
grammatikalisch gesehen aber mal schauen
ob der clever bot das versteht und was
er uns jetzt darauf antworte
aber falsche antwort